hey guys
um oh yeah thanks for waiting I'm really
happy to be here uh I guess to shortly
introduce myself my name is Ted Xiao I'm
a senior research engineer at the Google
brain team I've been on working on
robotics now for the past five years
I've touched upon a few topics including
multitask learning uh reinforcement
learning and then lately just broadly
thinking about how we can scale robots
um to make sure that they can actually
work in the wild in the real world
I guess today I'll be talking about
quite a few different topics but as a
first preface I guess um the first thing
to know is that our team is pretty
massive now all of these projects are
huge collaborations with some products
have more than 40 people working on
these for many years so these are large
efforts and I'm just very fortunate to
call myself to be on teams of very smart
people and secondly uh some of my takes
are spicier more controversial than
others and so all of those opinions are
definitely only my own and don't reflect
those of Google or anyone else on the
team
um so with that out of the way yeah
welcome to my tedx stop
if
so I think maybe some of you have seen
you know a lot of the cool robot videos
learning videos out in the wild these
days but I am more excited than ever and
it's not just hype I think I think
there's been a fundamental shift in how
researcher and Robotics view learning
over the past two years and I think the
shift has a lot to do with all the
trends happening more broadly in
Foundation modeling in large-scale
Internet models
um across different fields like language
audio and so on but I think my goal
today is to convey to UI I am
particularly excited about this time
today right now and why there's been a
very fundamental one a degree paradigm
shift I think across the robot learning
field and if you walk away from this
talk with just one thing and that's
you're slightly a bit more excited about
robotics than you were before or believe
that the time is now for these robots to
really start scaling exponentially and
doing something really cool I think then
my talk will have succeeded
um
let's see
the talk will have a few parts we're
going to start at a very high level and
just talk about why a foundation models
for foundation model for robotics at all
what that might look like and the
ingredients and recipe for how we might
get there then we'll dive into a few
different Works um pretty deeply that my
team has been very proud of over the
past year or two and finally we'll go
back to the high level and then zoom out
and think about what's next for robot
learning
so why a foundation model for robotics
is
one sec let me try to hide this thing
um no that's that's fine I'll keep that
bar there for now but the top bar says
why Foundation model for robotics
um you know being coined here at
Stanford and I'll use the phrases
internet scale model Foundation model
and large language model pretty
interchangeably throughout and I hope
it's pretty clear but generally when I'm
talking about these big monolithic
beasts that are training on tons of data
they have two very important properties
that I think are quite nice one is
emergence
um when very simple things kind of work
at a small scale they get a ton better
when you just scale things up more data
more compute larger models
um and what we see here is that when
these models even become good enough the
domain space of what they're good at and
able to do starts to go combinatorial
even larger and here for these two
points I would like to suggest two blog
posts I highly recommend one is from
Jacob steinhardt called more is
different for AI and this kind of links
the phenomenon that we see in other
Fields like physics or biology for
example individual water molecules will
behave very differently and have very
different let's say electrostatic forces
then they start to climb up Clump up and
start behaving as a liquid altogether we
see this in herds of animals flocking
patterns we see this in humans and
economies we see this all across
different fields and now even in AI we
see models that are doing stuff that
would not be even possible where they
had a smaller scale but when they've
reach some critical scale in size they
start to work really really well this is
documented by um Jason in uh his blog
post emergence and loms which you see
this plot on the bottom left
successfully across a bunch of different
tasks whether it's modular arithmetic or
purging question answering the success
rate is basically flat until these
models get big enough good enough and
then the successfully just kind of
Skyrocket and uh that's why I think this
these are particularly exciting so yeah
a question
great question and I'm really glad you
asked we have
I'm pretty excited to present some
directions we have along that I hope
we'll answer a question in maybe about
10 minutes or so okay yeah but I think
that's the question on all of our minds
including myself
um so I think before we even get to the
feasibility or the existence of any
robotics Foundation models like is this
even needed and I think the argument
that I don't think is obvious um is that
I think emerging capabilities and
relying on these might be actually
indispensable for robotics to actually
work a lot of the research over the past
decades in robotics has been in one bin
one room one table one robot one
building even but these are so vastly
different from the orders of magnitude
more complex while real world situations
that humans operate in every single day
and I think to make that gigantic leap
we're gonna have to rely on this
emerging capability scaling curve where
things kind of work you have very canned
demos maybe you have you know a humanoid
robot program to backflip after hundreds
of Trials but going from that to like
the chaotic real world I think we're
gonna have to rely on this emergence
phenomenon for that
and I think maybe even intellectually or
academically it's also interesting to
think about why or why not a foundation
model for robotics might even work it's
worked in so many other domains there's
existence proofs in audio music coding
language another domain every single day
it seems with 3D models and and Beyond
um but if there is something very
special about robotics whether it's
embodiment or causality or physical
grounding then that is the barrier to
making this very simple recipe that's
working all these other domains if there
is something special about robotics that
causes this recipe to fail I think
that's quite interesting to study why
that is I'm personally an optimist I
don't think there is some magical Secret
Sauce that's going to keep robotics from
being tackled with the same formulas and
recipes that works elsewhere but you
know I think this is a function I'd like
to find out the answer to
and so maybe then instead of just
motivating this philosophically okay we
need Foundation models Foundation models
are great let's try to build one for
robotics how do we actually do that well
um I think we can leverage a few
ingredients by standing on the shoulder
of Giants and looking at other domains
uh the first one is looking at different
design principles of ml scaling um from
other domains uh let's look first at
high capacity architectures the topic of
this class today
um uh ideas such as self-attention as
all the different ideas Encompass for
the Transformer as Andre carpathy
famously said it's like a magical
Universal differentiable computer that's
very general very robust and very
remarkably scalable on many different
dimensions let's use those
um we should also Leverage The more
guiding principles that have been seen
the scaling laws the trends this year's
chinchilla uh you know we not only have
to scale the model size we also have the
sale compute and we also have to scale
the number of unique tokens in the
Corpus of the vast data sets that we
train on but if we do all three together
this has been shown to reliably have a
pretty good chance of succeeding um no
matter what domain you're looking at
and so and and finally what that kind of
means and I think this is actually going
to come up later is that data set size
seems Nevada these days a lot more than
quality even if you have some sentences
on Wikipedia that are misspelled or some
some you know falsehoods or some things
that aren't so desirable if in aggregate
your data set is diverse enough and
interesting enough
um these things will hopefully wash out
in the mix
foreign number two the proliferation of
the internet Scale Models themselves not
just the principles
what's exciting and I'm sure it's you
know definitely been very shocking for
both experts and lay people alike is
that a lot of these generative models
across many different modalities have
been experiencing emerging capabilities
and have been surpassing all of our
wildest expectations time and time and
again but even when we think that we're
exhausted all this stuff is too much
it's not going to work something will
come out and completely blow me out of
the water and I think this trend will
definitely keep continuing and I think
uh in addition to that they not only
will continue coming on and accelerate
more rapidly they're going to happen
with whether or not like we do anything
um you know in in the grand scale of
speaking me as a robotics researcher or
you know you and and whatever subfield
you're on there are parts of machine
learning that likely you'll probably not
ever touch in at least the near future
and those parts will be seeing
tremendous breakthroughs and scaling and
new capabilities coming online every
single week
and uh you can look at this not only in
the impressiveness of the models but
also the acceleration of progress the
time scales in which new models are
being released while where large
collaborations are being worked on by
many groups and then you know being
available to access for all to use and
build upon
and the final ingredient and this trend
is more of a robotic specific one but it
is a vast shift from online robotic
learning where where robots collect
experience online make actions and learn
through
um trial and error to an offline setting
where we decouple the data generation
process from the data consumption
process as we've seen in all these other
Foundation modeling domains these big
internet scale data sets are so diverse
and they're static we just scrape them
once or scrape them multiple times
continuously but we aggregate a
continuous pile that's just growing here
we see either the pile data set from a
Luther or Lyon 5B for uh image paired
image text
um and and these are pretty big and
their orders of magnitude more than what
we've seen before and they are
definitely a key ingredient to why other
domains have been doing so well at
training these big foundation models
and
this coming back to robotics then I'd
like to take a brief detour into how the
shift came to be because it's very easy
to stay in a sentence yeah robotics is
offline more than online and this is
coming as kind of a no-brainer to many
folks who are coming from other domains
like this is the way things are done
well in robotics this has been a very
big shift
um and I think robotics has also been
synonymous with RL reinforcement
learning for a lot of people and I think
increasingly this is becoming less true
and so I'd like to take you down a brief
um trip down the history of my team for
slide up and talk says brief history of
Robotics at Google
um and yeah of course thanks and I think
this is not just for dramatic Exposition
it's really to try to guide you through
how drastically our team's thinking has
kind of evolved over the years and how
that's going to inform the design
decisions and the and the kind of risks
and research directions that we take um
in the specific projects I'm going to
show coming up thank you
um so in 2016 uh some of you may have
seen this we had what we call the arm
Farm seven Kuka robots in a room
collecting picking data 24 7. and this
was doing on policy RL in the real world
we were the first team to kind of say
hey can we can we even do this
um with the goal of saying can we do
end-to-end robot learning with results
in the real world this was kind of risky
at the time it was not a common take and
from that we developed several
interesting research directions that we
started exploring we looked into stuff
like um uh qtops which is a q learning
method working on continuous control
actions uh while taking a vision inputs
we worked on on cyclegan to transform
simulation-based images into real real
looking images for Sim surreal we looked
at concurrential we'll probably get
robots moving faster and more
efficiently in the real world I'm sorry
do you have a question yeah
yeah great question and
um that one I think was basically uh the
arms would pick stuff up from the bin if
they messed up and it fell out well we'd
come back the next morning and there'd
be objects scattered all throughout the
room so there was no reset but if they
missed a little bit the objects would
fall back into the bin and hopefully be
in a position where they could pick them
up again
oh yeah of course
um Chad thanks I'll do that in the
future um this specific question was for
this 24 7 arm Farm how did we do resets
and the answer is well we didn't we
designed the bin so that they were kind
of banked so that object slightly missed
they would fall back in the bin we
aren't themselves maybe add more
diversity to the training data but this
was doing off policy online RL with Q
learning when we mixed it with Sim data
deploy it again
next uh we kind of went through this
consolidation phase around 2020 when
we're like all right this is pretty cool
and you know but we want to get out of
the bin how do we do more complex tasks
and a more practical setting that could
be closer to something that humans would
want to use that's more General every
day there we kind of settled on this
office micro kitchen environment if
you've heard of the famous Google micro
kitchens
um and I think this was the setting we
decided to what's operate in
um and there we started collecting data
we scaled our real operations and then
we kind of scaled approaches to some
different things and I think uh in the
bottom right here is like the more
mechanized reset version I would say of
the arm Farm here we had a bin that
folded in half and this was doing
multitask RL in the real world and the
bin would flip in half dumping objects
from one side to the other so you could
do more interesting tasks whereas the
arm plan was pick anything up now you
could say hey pick up the carrot and
place the Tomato onto the plate and then
the bin would flip and you'd reset some
other works looks like at UM multitask
invitation learning this is bc0 and then
we also look at stuff like combining
reinforcement learning with imitation
learning bootstrapping
but in 2020 uh once again we realized we
were working on a ton of different
directions and we wanted to consolidate
and I think the two main things that
were really bothering us at the point at
the time where we were hitting two main
walls across all these methods some of
them were plateauing at this 50 to 70
percent uh you know rough range in the
real world and other methods were
requiring very specific data
distributions they had to be on policy
or they could only use demonstrations or
they blah blah blah like there are so
many different nuances and like gotchas
to all these different methods and all
these different drawbacks and so the
question we posed was we're open to any
any method any strategy that will enable
us to solve tasks in a very performant
matter more than 90 in the real world
and also that can scale with some kind
of data that we can collect you know and
maybe this is a bit more relaxed than
let's say an academic setting where
you're much more resource constrained
but at the end of the day you know even
our team does not have infinite money we
still have a certain number of robots
operators and we're constrained by the
laws of physics so we need some way to
acquire more data that we can then learn
from and so we're all scratching our
heads thinking about this for a few
months since spring 2022.
we decided on going with multitask
imitation learning so this was a vast
departure from the 24 7 arm farm this
was a vast evolution of how we
approached the problem we found that you
know with enough you know gentle care
and love multitask imitation learning
was able to hit these 90 numbers and it
was able to get better with more
demonstrations these aren't the cheapest
thing but it was able to scale with
additional demonstrations which was the
sign of life that we were looking for so
that brings us to less than a year ago
our team was deciding this is the path
forward at least in the near-term future
but
um
maybe you know we could just think about
how the approach we were taking here
might also spread out in the future and
we might be able to bring back these
other threads uh for example um if now
that we're decoupling this data
collection of demonstrations or Etc from
how you learn from them with a multitask
invitation learning policy maybe in the
future then do something like offline RL
but I think at a high level now I've
just you know in in a few short minutes
just compressed six years of very bitter
lessons that our team has been learning
and I think from where we are today and
looking back even just two years ago if
you told me that the strategies were to
point today could just scale the way
they are I probably would not have
believed you
um
great question so I think task
conditioning is definitely still was an
open question at the time
um but I think with this work uh BC zero
uh we we found that language was able at
least in a templated language
um kind of representation was good
enough where we could direct I think bc0
was over 80 tasks so they were they were
very templated like pick grapes or like
move grapes onto plate or drag this
across black drag clock across table and
I think um this representation was still
enough where you're learning a good
number of skills that you're passing in
essentially a one-hot ID into your
policy Network and it will learn to
imitate that and for each one of those
80 tasks we'd collect hundreds or
thousands of demonstrations
and I will touch upon the specifics of
that a bit later too
um
so yeah today and or at least in 2022
let's do offline methods let's decouple
data generation from data consumption
and let's take these three lessons now
that we touched upon let's take the
design principles of ml scaling and then
figure out what lessons can actually be
applied when we go look into the future
for a recipe for uh robot learning and
Foundation models
um the first lesson I think is very
important is these high-capacity
architectures like attention the second
I'll touch on later is data
interoperability tokenized tokenization
discretization
um and the second ingredient is the
proliferation of these models themselves
can we leverage them because they will
get better over time
um and I think here I would like to plug
my colleague Carol houseman's bidder
lesson 2.0 which is the bitter lesson
the first one from Richard sutson was
you should leverage methods that scale
with more compute and maybe in today's
day and age the lesson is that we should
leverage methods that are able to
utilize improvements in Foundation
models because they're going to get
better yeah so
2.0 one thing that's always concerned me
is suppose I have a set of methods
and I want to choose the methods that
are going to stay with more from here
before in this case scale with better
Foundation models the question is how do
I actually decide which of those methods
meet those criteria
yeah great question I think um and maybe
it's uh and I think that's a very I
don't have a good answer for that oh
sorry yeah yeah the question was um in
bitter lesson 1.0 and bitter lesson 2.0
the question is well that's great that's
the lesson but how do we actually decide
which methods meet this criteria and I
think you know my answer is it's not
always obvious and it's actually quite
tricky sometimes but uh maybe you know
sometimes you know what you can be very
confident that oh yeah this will
definitely scale um with more data and
compute and some that are same but
basically the more hard-coded you are
the more assumptions the more heuristics
you bake in the more you in our in our
day and age the more you rely on a
specific implementation of a specific
Foundation model of a specific class of
algorithm maybe that will be less robust
than a method that just assumes some
very abstract input and output and
assumes that how you get from that input
and output can improve over time and
maybe the algorithm itself even changes
all together so I think that would be my
take on the video Lesson 2.0 but this is
definitely still uh I think the jury's
still out on this things
and uh my my basic um my one of the
things I like to propose is that
language is the way that we can leverage
bitter lesson 2.0 if you have language
as the universal representation through
which all these foundations communicate
to each other whether it's you know
captioning or generation or whatnot I
think that's one way that we could
leverage a video Lesson 2.0
um and finally the third ingredient
offline robot learning decoupling data
generation from data consumption putting
these all together my recipe for how one
take at a modern attempt that embodied
intelligence would look like would be to
combine these large offline data sets
with high capacity architectures by
using language as the universal group
and in the works I'm going to present
shortly all of our different projects I
think in some way or another are
inspired by this philosophy
and now now that we've kind of um you
know understood the motivations and
potentially one possible approach
of course
large numbers
I'm curious to know which if any issues
are currently used bottlenecks not the
right word which of these are women got
it because it seems like we already have
our job like this if we have like
capacity architecture thing you know
there's architectures are related
language it seems like we already have
always components lessons on so why is
this that not a solved product
um the question was uh these it seems
like we have a lot of these ingredients
and so why hasn't robotics been solved
yet
um so I would argue that actually this
takes here and maybe I'm this is to the
wrong audience at the moment but I think
this is not very non-obvious across the
robotics field many people do not agree
with all of these much less two of these
or even any of these points and so I
think and also the existence of the
scale of how mature each of these
components are within robotics is at
very different stages and I would say
like and we can talk a bit later about
like for example like data scale or the
architectures that have kind of diffused
through osmosis from other ml domains
into robotics but I think we're still at
very different stages on how how much
people have actually bought into these
lessons and invested in them
yeah
I'm curious to know not asking you to
make names but the people who might not
be blinding to all these pieces one
um yeah yeah uh I I can probably I also
don't want to get into too much trouble
here but I'll I'll probably get myself
in a bit of hot water in a few slides so
I'll I'll expand upon out of it then
yeah
this is why you think they're wrong yeah
and I I would say that like me
personally and um you know not speaking
for my team but a lot of people on my
team are probably at the very extreme
end of learning scaling data-driven uh
you know Foundation model based uh let's
go big um and I think a lot of people
don't believe that and yeah happy to
discuss why later
maybe after the zoom as well so
yes
um so yeah uh well okay then let's let's
go ahead and dive in and see how this
recipe might actually percolate into
specific um domains
um and the first one is uh rt1 uh this
is a recent work from our group that
works on how we can scale imitation
learning and let's look at how we can
actually apply these first principles
so the first one is to consider what we
actually
um let's let's put ourselves into the
spring 2020 mindset we we've been
collecting demonstrations for a while
this is a ton of demos like a hundred
thousand over that was collected over
like a year and a half on Many Many
Robots on many many tasks that exists it
was expensive and over time this will
actually you know not trickle up at
insane amounts like we won't just get a
hundred thousand new high quality demos
every day this will grow over time but
it's not gonna you know grow for free
um and autonomous ways of doing this is
very hard as you saw earlier with mtop
with the bin reset mechanism or deepmind
has to work on RGB stacking where they
try to do autonomous resets and you know
the way that we're doing it right now or
at least um for this paper uh was human
tele operation um pioneered by BC zero
and that was very expensive as well so
this is going to be limited throughput
and finally uh bc0 used a resnet based
backbone and it was pretty good but it
found that it was very sensitive to
training distributions for example when
they remove data from some tele
operators they make the data more
performance got better and that's not
really a property we like right we want
more data even if it's not exactly the
same
um so the lesson here models need to be
robust and they need to generalize
cool so we have models need to be robust
and generalized what else do we have
well off the shelf models are pretty
slow if we take in these huge you know
Vision Transformers from other domains
they're not going to run on the real
robot uh we need to be able to run at a
pretty high frequency um they need to be
reactive inference time needs to be slow
because all our models are Vision based
and finally uh we want our data to be
able to understand language as I
mentioned if language is the universal
glue our data set already has some
language and we want eventual models to
be very multimodal this is a first
principle that we need to bake in
what does this mean we can't just take
something existing we probably need to
design or at least modify something from
the ground up and let's take the best
practices that we've seen work in other
fields
and so we worked for a bit and uh we
came up with this architecture for rt1
again once again this was a large team
with a bunch of different contributions
and I'll just go through a few of them
here
um at a high level uh rt1 is robotics
Transformer um it operates at three
Hertz it takes in a visual input from
the robot or on RGB camera as well as a
natural language instruction there the
image is patified and fed into a film
efficient net um tokenizer that's then
passed into token learner which I'll
talk about soon
um and then also the language
instructions are tokenized
um and then they are put into the same
Transformer and then finally we output
discretized
um actions as tokens and send that to
the real world in three Hertz in closed
loop
um this Transformer is a decoder one we
use a sparse categorical entropy
objective for Action prediction by
applying a causal mask we use the
pre-trained efficient net backbone and
we also use token learner for verify for
faster inference
um diving a little bit deeper oh sorry
yeah a question
great question
um so
the image token when it goes in from so
each image is the you know the high
fidelity RGB image from the camera we
split that up into 81 separate patches
and so each patch is you know it's
spatially just like the the square there
um but the cool thing is that uh what
token learner does here uh this thing
here
um is it's a previous work from our
group that takes in a bunch of possible
um uh you know image patches and
dynamically select which of those image
patch tokens are more relevant for the
tax at hand given the existing context
so from those 81 image patch tokens we
sub-sample eight of them to use for
inference and this happens at every time
step
and that process is learned which of the
eight patches are relevant at any given
moment
um and otherwise we're sending in way
too many tokens and the context length
would explode and we wouldn't be able to
do inference on Roblox we are also
passing in a single sequence length of
six images
um history is quite important when
you're doing temporarily uh coherent
tasks in the real world where things
like physics and you know exactly this
this nuanced detail of what the objects
are doing in relation to each other into
your robot those details really matter
um and in total the the model size is 35
million parameters
um which is quite a bit smaller than a
lot of these other uh you know huge
internet scale models
and finally one main difference here is
action discretization before a lot of
the products we're doing uh we're doing
continuous control and if you think
about it right our robot does have um we
do end effector post control on position
control and there uh the real world is a
continuous State space but um and and to
do that we we had to come up with many
algorithmic Novelties for example a a
cem actor that did basically sampling of
these continuous action spaces to
propose the highest ones that would get
rated by the Q function and we do this
twice blah blah blah and but that's like
so sensitive but we needed to get
through that to get things to work but
now we just decided let's just uh you
know bin our actions it's only 256
discrete actions and let's just predict
those as tokens
you have this design required or
engineering environment about speed
latency reaction I think we say that
that necessitates on a relatively small
model which makes sense but one lessons
by either data you can do before or
analytics so I guess one of the person
is how do you balance these off in the
sense that if you want to have lots of
parameters that have a really powerful
model but on the other hand you want to
have very passive inputs yeah great
question and uh to repeat it the
question is um we kind of set a pretty
hard constraint with that 100
millisecond inference time yet a lot of
the lessons in Foundation modeling is
that you shouldn't be constraining
yourself against any Dimension whether
it's data set size compute or model
capacity and I think my initial answer
to that is that's a very great point and
something I think that's going to be
coming up as a severe bottleneck um in
the future but for for our initial case
I think this is more of an exploration
of whether these principles and even
scaling well beyond what we're looking
at now could work already on this 35
million is gigantic compared to a lot of
Prior work using for example resnet 34
or whatnot so this is already much
bigger than you know a lot of other
options and um maybe for now at least
it's the easiest it's it's the largest
scale we could go to roughly
um in the short term without having to
think of more tricks
um
gotta got it yeah we can talk about it a
bit later maybe I think I'd also love to
hear your thoughts too because it's very
non-obvious how we can get past um some
of these bottlenecks
really about to this they didn't give
you a medical computer with 100 things
to be used but everything else in the
same way they're disable your platform
you so do you think you see significant
Improvement even some sort of emerging
Behavior or the current pipeline for
this bigger models or do you think there
is more to this than to try to scaling
that and they're like limiting value
yeah great question um we ran some
ablations on uh model size I I might
have that in a few slides um but uh
maybe we can return to that then and if
not um
yeah but great question
um so yeah that that's the architecture
and I'll discuss some of the ablations
and the trends later on but maybe you
know this is a robotics lecture I should
show you some pretty visuals right
um so let's look at some evaluations we
did uh we compared against some
baselines one is uh gato um which you
might be familiar with
um and then other other ones BC zero the
resnet based one and we find that uh we
we evaluate on scene tasks versus unseen
tasks and we also uh embarrass the
shacker objects our normal data collect
looks like this top left picture three
cans on a gray desk that's basically it
and but then we push it further by
bringing in a lot more objects so that
the table is so cluttered that even as a
human sometimes it's hard to find the
object that you're actually looking for
we add in tablecloths to make the the
textures very different we bring it to
New micro kitchens um with new surfaces
all together and we find that rt1 is
more robust than these other different
methods
um
in this specific
good question uh question was um was the
gato model trained on our data or was it
uh just already included in gato oh the
answer is uh this data was not included
in gato and so we retrained the Gaga
model only on our data yeah
and uh yeah so here's just a different
visualization of the robot going out in
our micro kitchen and doing different
interesting things
um you can see here that it's trained on
one setting but then it goes into brand
new kitchen brand new countertops new
objects and it's able to do all of them
pretty robustly uh we also put it into
um a long Horizon setting
um using the second framework that we'll
talk about next
um but in these settings a lot of them
are mixing all of these generalization
capabilities and on the plot on the left
here we're using what we call
generalization levels inspired by the
Vemma paper that would basically
increasingly change more factors of
variation simultaneously and here we
found rt1 is the most robust
yeah good question
um we'll go into a bit more detail later
but I think at a high level tele
operators get a structured templated
command of like verb noun verb or
something um like like pick Coke can or
move Apple near sponge
um and they we have around 700 tasks set
up this way and they go ahead and
collect that data test done and then
later we have um we make sure that
successes are actually successes and we
discard stuff that's like unsafe for
example
oh yeah got it for this paper we we
utilize 130 000 demonstrations for this
yeah
great question I think a lot of Prior
work has also noted that
um when you have for example the
question was did you find that the the
trajectories in your data set were very
multimodal and I think what you mean by
that is that to go from point A to point
A to point B I can go left or I can go
right or I can go straight
um and I think this kind of diversity in
basically for a single image stage but
yet my data has three possible labels
that can have very bad effects sometimes
for us I think because we are using
teleopper demonstrations the data was
more homogeneous
um than perhaps like uh in the wild for
example there's a type of data function
called play data where operators just do
whatever they want and we label in
hindsight and I think our data is more
homogeneous than that but we did not
find a lot of the issues that we've seen
in Prior projects one
um potential answer is maybe it's it's
the it's the architecture itself but we
can talk about that later too question
uh great question uh we actually do have
a termination action so the policy
itself that's right so the question was
how do you determine when a episode is
complete and uh the policy is able to
predict terminate um because at the end
of each tele operation session the
operator can click the button and it's
marked as the episode's done
yeah I think for these evaluations we
were quite strict
um but definitely I think in some cases
uh you know maybe maybe if we're just
doing an experiment for ourselves we'll
have a dense reward scale of like grasp
the object and move closer graspy object
and almost got there if I messed up at
the end and we'll have like a grading
curve basically but for all these all of
these um stats I'm showing here it was
zero or one one fully complete zero was
not fully complete
cool
um and I think what was expecting
exciting maybe talking about the
multi-modaly aspect is then we pushed
the limit even further we were TR we
decided to train on very diverse data
distributions
um you're you're back by that yeah okay
um so right now you saw 130 to a
thousand demonstrations trained on this
everyday robot um a proprietary um
mobile manipulator but we were also
looking to trade on very different data
distributions with very different you
know action distributions very different
trajectories even very different visuals
objects tasks and to do that we included
two other data sources one was
simulation data which was kind of our
robot plot in sin but it looked quite
different and also this data was
collected with reinforcement learning
and not with teleopper demonstrations in
the past with all the IL plus RL work
that I mentioned we found that combining
these these two types of data was going
to be very difficult because RL beta has
very short actions um it's very quick
it's very optimized for the specific
reward function versus human collected
teleoperation data is a lot more you
know human life so to speak and finally
we revived a data set from many years
ago a 2018
um if you remember the Kuka project that
arm Farm has now been operational in
that state for many years now but we had
that data still and so we were hoping to
see if a different robot with a
different action space on different
objects with different visuals in a
different building could still be
combined with data from this micro
kitchen uh um data set that we train on
originally and what was very surprising
to me is that rt1 was able to learn from
all these very diverse data
distributions I had never seen a result
like this or any other architecture for
example a resnet or even another
learning method like reinforcement
learning could successfully learn on
such different data distributions
um so robustly and we evaluated for
example on combining Concepts so we
would have the original everyday robot
robot pick up objects that were only
seen in the Kuka project or we would put
objects only seen in simulation and see
if our policy could understand that so
it did seem like it could generalize
between objects it's seen in other data
sets and Concepts that had seen in other
data sets into the setting it was in now
in the real micro kitchen and that was a
very fun result yeah
great question
um yeah we just tokenized it and made
sure that the tokenization scheme was
kind of interoperable I think that was
the um I I can dive into that in a bit
later too yeah
um and no no that does not mean we can
send the exact actions for one robot to
another and have it execute it was more
just like in the data set I think even
by human inspection you can tell that
these are coming from two different
robots
um
so yeah uh let's look at some ablations
for the scaling laws that we're all here
for now
um we found that you know reducing data
size reduces performance but more
interesting maybe is Task diversity was
quite important here we have two
different Trends uh
um the uh green line is what happens
when we reduce the total amount of
episodes per task and then gray on here
the purple curve is for what happens
when you reduce the total number of
tasks when we found that having more
tasks is relatively more important than
having more data for each task
and I think this was a lesson that I
think is probably going to suggest
um ways that you know we should scale
robotics even further is not to just
collect more data of the same task in
the same settings but to go out into the
wild and get more diverse Behavior
great question uh question is how do you
define data diversity in this case um I
uh it's just a number of unique
structured templated commands that tele
operators receive so those 700 templated
commands but when you start reducing
them and only train on 500 or only trade
on 300 of them performance drops much
quicker than if we had take taken the
same proportional uh cuts to the total
yeah
still I guess I'm very familiar but I
don't know
uh
um
yeah I I don't think we um the question
was there seems to be almost a linear
correlation between a data size and
success rate and I think you know we
could apply some fancy like you know
scaling law you know trying to curve
fitting but uh we didn't look too much
into that because you know this is a
trend that we kind of expected we just
weren't sure about the the magnitude of
how much it would affect us
um and uh I think I don't have any
really good insights on this besides
that we see this phenomenon empirically
yeah
yeah and and great question so so the
question is oh yeah maybe this will just
go on indefinitely um or is there
something magical about you know January
2023 and I think this is maybe also a a
this is when we start to conflate um the
algorithmic Exploration with like the
Practical considerations of scaling real
world operations which was when we got
enough data our policies were hitting
you know saturating on these hitting
close to 100 we're like all right let's
connect collect another data set so we
basically collect until it's at 100 and
then we switch to something else
um but at this point what was
interesting is that when we kind of bet
really big on this rt1 architecture we
are we'd already been collecting demos
for a while so it was possible that we
had collected more than we needed and in
some cases it actually you could cut
tasks without losing too much
performance which was quite interesting
but
foreign
equal in terms of like their capacity
and entropy for different behaviors you
can learn from them and yeah that's
definitely true some tasks are much
easier we have a task that's just pick
up this object that's going to have much
less interesting stuff you can squeeze
out of it than you know moving something
into a drawer and then closing the
drawer um but yeah great question
um right now um ablations uh we also
trained without the big model size we
did it without pre-training without uh
you know with continuous instead of
discrete actions with with a lot of
aggressive actions without history
without the Transformer uh and I think
all these design choices did seem to be
required for robust performance
oh yeah of course
foreign
yeah I I think all I mean like and again
you know for for paper writing it's kind
of like the best thing that we can
empirically find that's that's the
method and then we'll figure out why
each of these are important and so uh
yeah I think what one surprising thing
here perhaps was that auto regressive
actions hurt you might think that
passing in more information is always
better than passing in fewer fewer
information but in this case uh maybe
conditioning on your previous actions
was kind of doing kind of like in
context learning it was doing online
systems identification to figure out
what
teleoc radar this data came from and
like how you can overfit to that
specific set of action history and so
removing that was actually better
um one interesting tidbit there
um cool then and uh maybe in the
interest of time I'll try to get through
the other ones uh a bit more quicker and
then we can maybe just do fewer uh we'll
I'll just uh do the questions at the end
if that's possible um just so we have
time to get through everything
um the next work here moving a bit away
from skill learning then and actually on
to the planning level I think the first
project took a lot of the design
principles of other fields um and uh
this offline robot learning Paradigm and
put it into the skill learning can we
actually bring that out to other parts
of the robotic system and the first work
here is say can if you remember here
back in this timeline in 2022 we started
thinking about oh yeah how do we scale
um this multitask imitation learning but
at the same time large language models
and you know other types of foundation
models are really picking up steam
whether it was Imogen or dolly two
um and we definitely wanted to figure
out how we could use those as well we
had come up with this rtu 2-1 design
that we're betting big on but um from
here we started to explore how all of
the beta lesson 2.0 we could start
utilizing Foundation models within the
context of our full stack system
the problem of doing this naively is
that language models are not completely
a very natural fit for robotics for
example
um if you're a robot in a kitchen you
ask a language model I sell my drink
what can you do language model will give
you stuff that's not very relevant it's
going to ask you to vacuum it it's going
to ask you to call cleaner or it's going
to apologize and these are not things
that the robot can do in your kitchen
with your spill drain to help you
and so there are two parts of this then
uh the one issue is that our robots are
limited they are very constrained with
what they can do they cannot do
everything but they can do certain
things and then the second problem is
that um the language models are also
constrained they don't know what the
robot sees they don't understand that
they are in a robot body in a micro
kitchen needing to do real stuff in the
physical world and so we need to get the
robots to speak language model language
and then the language model to see to
speak robot language
um to do this we present secan uh in the
same setting you know please put an
apple on the table uh we score on the
predictions of the language model on a
constrained set of tasks that we know
the robot has been trained to do and
then we also take the affordance
function from the robot and affordance
function is a estimation of given some
kind of State uh what the robot is able
to do um how confident it is that it can
successfully accomplish that task in the
given state in our case we use something
like a value function from reinforcement
learning which kind of accomplishes this
quality given these two values these two
scores we have the confidence from the
language model and then the confidence
from the robot we can combine these and
then hopefully the combined prediction
is both something that's going to be
very semantically relevant for the high
level instruction finding an apple is
the first step and please put an apple
on the table but it's also something
that the robot can do there's no robot
on the frame but it knows that it's been
trained to find an Apple so it can
navigate around to find it and so
hopefully you can do this then in closed
loop and then keep on going and
predicting a high level plan from the
language model that's grounded with the
affordance function of what the robot
understands
um there's a video here of the uh
station doing different stuff but you
know happy to share it later um offline
uh it's very cool trust me it's the
greatest thing since I spread wow
um and yeah some numbers then uh we
tested this out on very long Horizon
instructions encompassing more than 10
separate navigation and manipulation
skills in the micro kitchen that you see
on the bottom right
um we evaluated
um hundreds of different evaluations on
this and we tested out very a lot of
different concepts including things like
rephrasing by using single Primitives by
drawing um instructions that just came
from uh you know colleagues and Friends
uh and then we and we found that uh
while they were failures in both the
language model planning stuff side where
it would predict the wrong path for the
current situation as well as on a policy
execution side even when it gets a good
plan the robot will mess up sometimes
overall it was still doing quite well
um and now let's kind of take this back
to the lesson I I think this is a very
great example of how we can leverage
um internet uh internet scale Foundation
models as they get better when we
started the project we started with a
language model called flan from Google
um throughout our implementation uh Palm
came online Pathways language model and
when that happened we were able to just
hot swap it in and uh performance just
kind of got better for free without us
having to do anything by just assuming
that language was the API the plan just
has to be any string it can come from
any Source it can come from a human it
can come from a language model but we
improve that language model the system
gets better overall
um and here you see with the scaling
size is as the model LOM increased in
size our planning performance got even
better
um and some cool tricks here to get it
working well how did we actually produce
this plan well just by prompting um as
is the ridge these days uh with Chain of
Thought um and with better prompting of
just giving examples of here's some
great robot plans now give me a new plan
starting with this high level
instruction uh we saw that the robot
could do all things from uh
understanding different languages to uh
asking asking them to be very complex
reasoning like hey give me something
caffeinated or I don't do caffeine
anymore get me something like you know
better
um or I could bring me a healthy snack
versus bring me a unhealthy stack second
was able to link a reason through all of
these
Let's uh you know I think that was our
kind of the first Contact of Robotics
with language models on our team and it
was the first exploration into how these
two worlds could overlap
um there was definitely still
improvements though and in a monologue
we try to improve those further by
bringing in Vision language models
the idea here is that uh you know we had
very high plan rate success uh with uh
say can but unfortunately it wasn't
really able to recover from failures
what I mean by that is that the language
model would not really get updates of
what was going on in the world so that
if this was a planet proposed go to the
table pick up a Coke bring it to you but
you messed up again the cocaine you
dropped it on the floor it would still
continue trying to bring it to you put
it aside but all of that does not really
matter anymore because you dropped the
Coke can and so in this work
um in our monologue we were really
hoping to figure out how we could add
closed-loop Dynamic feedback from the
environment into this planning process
let's take that exact same example
um now instead of just directly
predicting every instruction maybe we
add back some feedback from the scene
also conveyed using language as the
universal API here the scene can tell
you what's actually in them maybe uh the
robot asks a question now in the robot
this is a language model asking the
clarification question maybe here a
human response or another language model
then you can predict action uh the next
task to do once the landing model has
enough context and maybe even add in
stuff like success detection
um and so on and so forth how do we do
this then well
um the first thing that we Implement is
what we call passive scene description
just using either an off-the-shelf
engineered heuristic using object
detection models something like vile uh
you can describe the scene in text and
just convey all that context to the
language model
for active scene description this is
maybe similar to visual question
answering if you're familiar with that
field uh the language model can actually
propose active queries that it's curious
about in the scene maybe to make sure
that has enough context to move on and
here either a human can provide the
answer or in the future a vqa model as
they improve can provide that
and finally for Success detection uh
this is very important to allow the
language model planner to know when to
try to retrace something
um here we take in the first and last
image fine tune a clip success detector
and use that to provide binary success
failure information back to our language
model
um
and for the results wise we can see a
very similar second long Horizon
evaluation but here we actually what's
interesting um is that we're able to and
and basically Implement all these
different automated feedback mechanisms
on the robot and so that it's able to
reason and recover from things here you
see it's going to try to
um go to the table
um but the humans actually been saying
hey I changed my mind uh and then it
changes the human changes mind again
asking it to go back and forth and the
robot's able to you know maybe we're
kind of torturing the language model at
this point but the language also able to
replan and you know make sure that the
human intent is satisfied
um we also tried I'm not sure if this
video shows it uh but situations where
we did adversarial inputs where I walked
around and just kind of knocking objects
out of the robot's hands and um forcing
the success detector to tell it hey you
messed up you know try again
um
and uh we also tried this out on a
couple different domains a simulated
tabletop manipulation domain as well as
a real world manipulation domain and we
found that this was uh much better than
say can or let's say just only using um
visual features themselves with
something like clipboard
and I think here uh it really speaks
towards
um a trend that I've really come to
appreciate uh in 2018 a robotics
Professor once said that when they look
at all the different things preventing
robot learning from scaling tremendously
they thought the bottleneck was high
level of semantic planning about
reasoning about common sense and I think
in 2022 and 2023 language models can
provide a One path of how this can kind
of be offloaded at least in the interim
and I think if language models are the
API then you can just bring in these
Vision language models as object
detectors get better as success
detectors as eqa as landfalls get better
you can bring them all into the fold and
the ACT is kind of a life vest if your
robot currently does not have common
sense reasoning uh these other models
can act as a scaffold in their life fast
to bring you up to par with what they
currently love and maybe then in the
future you'll get beyond what the
language models know but in the short
term it does seem that we can leverage
them to accelerate what we can do in the
real world
um moving on now from we saw now how
language models could do planning we saw
how Vision language models could help
planning and now we're going to switch
gears a bit and think about how Vision
language models can help other aspects
of the bottlenecks that robot learning
faces
um one of these is that a data
collection is very expensive as we
mentioned before we did have this 130
000 episode demonstration data set
um but it was collected over a year and
a half at significant cost
um both in resources and time and money
um and uh with many many robots and of
course these tasks too were also
a bit limited right we use 700 very
templated commands instructions that we
give to Tele operators because we knew
that this was this would scale right if
we collected enough data for each of
these templated tasks we could do that
specific task
um and here's the the flow that someone
was asking about earlier we give this
cocaine instruction the operator
controls the robot in the real world
finished the task mark step so to
terminate and then uh you know shade
that out to this big orange data set and
that big orange data set is what we
train on in all the previous projects
for the control policies
what we originally considered was adding
a bit of crowdsourced hindsight
annotation if you're familiar with it
with a hindsight experience replay
um in reinforcement learning with gold
conditioning uh with you know maybe the
robot did something that wasn't just
this high level templated instruction
you could ask a human to describe more
verbosely what the robot did maybe it
picked up the cocaine that was on the
right side of the table maybe it picked
it up and then knocked it over maybe it
moved it very slowly to the middle
there's a lot of semantic diversity
encompassing this uh demonstration that
was that is not totally you know uh
caught by this high level templated pick
Coke can instruction so we labeled um
three percent of this big orange data
set with these very verbose descriptions
um and next we uh kind of Applied the
pseudo-label strategy strategy that's
been seen in other fields such as video
pre-training with their inverse Dynamics
model well instead we apply that to the
instructions to the semantics of what's
contained in your data set so step one
we pre-train a clip model
um on your small label data set of three
percent of your main data
then you go ahead and use that trained
BLM data to label all of the templated
instruction demonstrations that you had
before that 130 000 episode data sets
now you have a relabel data set which
has a large diversity of interesting
semantic instructions
um and then we plug in all of these data
sets into rt1 and just train a language
condition Behavior cloning policy
similarly to how we would normally with
even though normally we just use dataset
B the orange one now we use all three
data sets
and then finally we evaluate on entirely
new unseen instructions
um in the prior works right we were
evaluating mainly on the 700 templated
instructions but in this work we
actually go beyond that we can type in
you know almost anything you want that
you think might succeed and you can
phrase it how you can you can add typos
you can even do it by referring to
semantic Concepts you can add spatial
Concepts and we see how it does
um the reason that this might work uh
maybe visually to represent this is here
are the Disney embeddings
um on the left and the right it's the
same embeddings but on the left they're
colored by the original templated
instruction that was used to collect
that episode and on the right is what
the vision language model thinks um if
it's allowed to put a free-form natural
language caption and assign it to that
episode you see that on the left you
have these big clusters of pick cocan is
like you know hundreds or thousands of
episodes but we all just call them pick
Coke can on the right then we can then
expand those Concepts and say actually
this episode is picking up the red
cocaine this this episode is picking up
the clump of cocam this is picking up
the cocaine that's next to the chip bag
and so you can get a lot more mileage
out of the same underlying data set by
just using language as the diversity
mechanism through which you kind of
expand the concepts that you're
considering and for example in the
middle you see
um you know open top drawer can become
hold and pull out the top drawer we have
stuff like the center left for the
middle um for the Middle episode for the
bottom one pick Green rice chips from
white bowl becomes lift up the chip bag
from the bowl and drop it at the bottom
left corner of the table so you had a
lot of these semantic um you know
spatial Concepts that are now going to
be in your target supervised labels
I have a question regulations
um
yeah
um great question so I I guess if I can
rephrase a bit um the problem is that
like it's actually a very um difficult
and uh perhaps even attractive problem
of how you map all the linguistic
Concepts you see out in the wild down to
like maybe like embodied specific uh
types of episodes and like
here maybe I would say is that we are
definitely introducing a lot of our
pliers and our biases onto like maybe
what we call as left you mean left 10
centimeters left two centimeter meters
like like what do words mean and these
definitions what do they mean to us to
the crowd compute Raiders that generated
these captions what do they mean to the
robot what do they mean to the language
models maybe these are all slightly
different but the hope is at least if
they're roughly similar we'll get like
directionally correct improvements so I
I would say the nuances of this specific
hard lines of definitions and like
actual like you know semantic meaning of
these words I think that's maybe out of
scope right now but maybe something
we'll dive into further at a higher
level though I think basically the bar
is just so low we have these 700
template instructions that are basically
one hot IDs and we just want to make
those closer to natural language
um even if by a little
um and I think at least we're we're
trying to get towards that with these
Vision language models that are cap came
automatically I hope that answers your
question
and uh we also compared to a few bass
lines
um on the top left here we look at what
if we only train on this three percent
of the these fancy human rated labels
what if we only train on the original
rt1 data sets what if we train on both
of these and what if we train on both of
these plus all of the predictions given
by our BLM and what's interesting here
is that uh you know really labeling
seems to universally help uh we we
evaluated only on novel instructions
that was new for this project it's the
first time on a robotics project where
we only tested on something I could type
whatever I thought I'll type it in and
that became the the test set and we just
had to make sure that it was never
contained in the the training coverage
um and you see all these interesting
examples on the right here of stuff like
move the lonely object to the others I I
have no idea how this worked
um stuff like you know just lifting the
yellow rectangle talking about colors
talking about move the right Apple to
the left here we actually had two apples
in the scene and actually in our
training demonstration data we never
collected scenes with duplicate objects
just because you know we thought of this
multiple modality problem if you just
say pick cocannon there's two Coke cans
it's going to be very difficult to
figure out which one to do but with
language labeling it seems like maybe
you could do that now so even though we
never trained on scenes with two apples
now you can evaluate on them and just
specify with language which Apple you
want to go for and it was working pretty
reasonably
um and finally for the last example here
I thought it was kind of interesting uh
a single cocan we try to do a novel
Behavior Uh push towards the left was
not a templated instruction we only had
move cocan near Y where Y is another
object near apple with cocaine in your
sponge so pushing this motion of just
pushing the the cocaine into air
essentially was not something that we
ever encompassed but maybe it was in one
of the labels maybe like if you've seen
like a smooth Coke can near Apple and
the apples on the left and you saw blue
cocan near sponge and the sponges on the
left you would General the model can
generalize and be like Oh left means
this side of the table not a specific
object
um so maybe that's what's happening but
it's very unclear this is as I said uh
you know just I I type I thought of
something I typed it and just saw what
happened uh and we definitely hope to
explore this more quantitatively in the
future
um bottom left course is I think
comparing against non-visual
augmentation so maybe you can also get
these interesting Concepts just from
language alone right here we had adding
random noise or we do Mad Lib Style Just
swapping out words or we even use a LOM
gpd3 in this case to propose rephrasings
of existing instructions but I think my
takeaway there is that you really need
visual grounding for the visual language
model to say actually yeah this caption
is factually accurate at this given
point in time and that it's you know
something perhaps that um would be
interesting for a robot that fine-tuning
process provides both
children died
yeah yeah definitely uh these are just
some subsets of five of these evaluation
instructions but we had over 60 of them
uh we didn't do a full quantitative
ablation for example as we did um in rt1
we had this like seen in unseen task set
and that was compositional you'd see you
know move Coke near Apple and you would
see move Apple in your sponge but we'd
hold out move Coke near spun and we
would test that out well in this case I
think we can go much be more beyond that
because our language is completely free
form the compositional space of what you
can kind of combine is just going to be
much larger so we did try a little bit
to answer your question we tried some
combinatorial evaluations but there's
definitely a lot more thoroughness that
we could do there too
um how am I doing on time okay 10
minutes um maybe I'll try to wrap up
pretty soon then uh the dial of takeaway
then is that um two parts right lesson
two leverage Foundation models let's use
them as data documentation and lesson
three let's make sure that our offline
data set you know is robust enough where
these different behaviors exist and you
can describe them in language if you
don't have enough diverse behaviors no
matter how good your labeling is you
probably can't elicit all the
interesting Concepts that you want to
learn from
um and maybe most exciting for me here
was that actually some label noise is
okay notoriously in supervised learning
and imitation learning you need very
clean labels that are always 100 True
right you don't want to be learning from
like noisy data where some like you know
large percentage is just not accurate
but in our case um it seems that like
some label noise was okay the vision
language models was not always
predicting factually accurate
descriptions of the scene
um and I think this definitely hurt um
when it got too high the noise but at
smaller level it definitely still seemed
uh to be okay and robust enough to
handle that
so that was a deep dive then on some
individual works that use this big
recipe of language Foundation models
offline data sets in different parts of
the robot system
and this was the kind of pitch at the
beginning and I hope uh you at least see
a little bit of how our team has tried
to take these principles and apply them
to accelerating robot learning in the
real world
um as we see these different types of
ingredients and lessons map onto
different parts of the robot system
altogether for skill learning right that
was rt1 that we talked about for
planning that was stay can and then
adding the close of feedback with vision
language models that was inner monologue
for low-level control we didn't talk
about this today but an exciting work
from our team is actually using language
models to predict code that's executed
on the robot directly perhaps as
low-level controllers
um language models you know they read
textbooks they read they've read raw
stocks they've read uh you know ur5
documentation code and they can write
code for these robots and we can execute
that
um for data augmentation we saw dial
with vision language models uh and also
um I didn't talk about this here but for
object-centric representations for
things like feature activation math for
specific objects we can use those as
task representation
um for mapping a scene and in NL map
they did that uh for object mapping
object-centric navigation
um around the micro kitchen that we
looked at
um and I think hopefully in the next you
know coming weeks and months uh we have
a few more rows and entries to add here
as well um but I think uh this kind of
mindset is a very exciting research
direction of how you can apply these big
high-level Concepts about Foundation
models and offline data sets and you
look at what exists in the robot systems
of today and you find many gaps and
opportunities still available where we
can do everything from exploratory
pilots on how this might look like all
the way to more extensive valuations and
really building out robust systems I
think both of these have value
so I'll I'll uh conclude with just
saying that uh it was very fun exploring
all of these complementary directions
but there are still some major questions
of how we can take these Concepts even
further and how these Trends and ideas
might even evolve moving forward as
Foundation models get better as more
data set becomes available online as
more data becomes homogenized and
tokenized and interoperable and I think
a lot of the concepts from other fields
like uh Linguistics and vision and from
you know all of the uh big scaling kind
of level questions that are being
pioneered
um in language-based Foundation models
hopefully those kind of ideas can
trickle down to robotics maybe even
robotics can provide something back by
providing embodied action causal data
sets that maybe might improve the
quality of reasoning of some of these
large language models that are not
embodied
um with that though I guess I'd like to
um you know thank everyone for your time
and for uh Davidson providing me and uh
open to any questions about the papers
or just at a high level as well thank so
much
um
a lot of problems
yeah great question so the question I
guess is like uh what about tasks that
require more semantic reasoning like uh
you know operating at a certain speed or
with maybe like I don't know numerical
reasoning within the question the pump
itself
um I would say um so for a lot of the
more common sense reasoning like you
know uh throw away three Coke cans uh
you know after another I think um you
know the language model is very good at
that right now so for the second planner
it will predict you know throw away the
Coke can three separate times
um for the low level skill policy
learning though I think um that's more
of a that's more High variance I would
say um and definitely for right now we
don't really
um condition on speed or how you do it
exactly but that's definitely maybe
something that I could do if if you
could be label with like pick up the
code can slowly versus pick up the
cocaine quickly maybe that is something
a vision language model code recognize
okay
great question uh the question was at
what scale
um do we see like combinatorial
generalizations start to occur uh maybe
between like you've seen colors of one
block and then you want to evaluate on a
new color um and I I think that's a
great question and unfortunately my
answer is going to be very vague and it
depends it depends on how you define
your tasks it depends on the scale of
your data set and it depends on like the
concepts that you're trying to
generalize across I think um there's
been uh numerous attempts to kind of
basically uh formalize what it means to
generalize within uh you know learning
and within robotics even within like the
specific settings we consider and I
don't think there are any clear trends
like of where you can say oh yeah this
is the number I need to hit where you
know I can generalize across XYZ
Dimensions um like you could evaluate
all of those but I don't think it will
help you predict new trends at least
right now I think we're probably I know
this is just me talking I would say
where one order of magnitude off before
we can start to make very broadly
generalizing statements about
generalization capabilities I think you
know add one or two more zeros to our
data set size and we can start to talk
about that um in terms of task object
skills yeah
um
done
yeah very astute observation um so the
question the question was that in say
can uh the value functions that predict
these scalars on the right here for the
affordances
um are only storing a certain limited
number of tasks so is that the
bottleneck and I would say yes 100
scaling the number of tasks that your
system is able to do that you can then
give to the planner as its Buffet of
options to choose that is the bottleneck
right no matter how good your planner is
if you can only do like three tasks
there's only certain like combinations
of those three tasks that it can do to
you know map onto a high level
instruction so as you add more tasks as
the low level skill capabilities of your
robot increases uh you're kind of like
adding Precision to like the the um
coverage of the high level instructions
that your robot can try to do
um so that's a that's one of the main
bottlenecks I see today
thank you
great question um so have we tried rt1
with rohf or with RL
um I think
the short answer is I think we have some
stuff in the works that is doing that
but right now for all of our projects
currently we're just using this
implementation learning loss again I
think I I viewed this multitasking
mutation bet that we're making as kind
of an existence proof it works it's not
cheap but it kind of does work and it
does scale and that at least is a good
starting point and our main you know
hope over the next months and years is
can we improve beyond that can we add
back in offline Improvement you know can
we add in our L back to the equation
somehow I'm an RL person at heart so I
really hope so
foreign
[Music]
yeah a good question I I
um so I I regarding task balance and
whether like text only data is
sufficient for helping like motor
control learning
um I think uh my hope is that when you
know model models when we experience
emergence in both the robotic space and
we've already seen emergence in the
language space at some point maybe these
reasoning Concepts will start to
transfer between the two I would Point
them to one interesting paper which is I
think can Wikipedia help reinforcement
learning um from um Shane and some other
uh folks they pre-train you know a large
policy Network on like you know Auto
aggressive token prediction on Wikipedia
just text only and they use that to
initialize like control for Atari games
and this actually helped so you know
maybe this is philosophical but maybe
there's something about decision making
reasoning that transfers between text
and action data so
right
my other question is foreign
great question
um I I definitely agree uh you know
passing in six images is not going to be
enough when you're executing tasks for
minutes at a time like clean my whole
house and then you can only pass in the
last like you know two seconds like come
on um so I I think that's definitely
going to be a limitation as our tasks
set more complex in the long Horizon
um and I think here it's another open
question too uh is context length we
have high dimensional images even with
token learning for for reducing the
number of patches that we pass through
it's still you know very high
dimensional and we quickly hit the
context length cap can we do how do we
you know improve it Beyond this maybe
it's like retrieval Transformers or some
other kind of mechanism
learning
great question I think um we are hoping
to explore that in the future but with
this like context length limitation we
are already near the context length
capacity with just the six images alone
much less uh you know passing in whole
trajectories of zero shot behavioral
fuse shot Behavior we wish to see
um so 2bd yeah
cool thank you guys